[Música]
y muy noble a todos un aplauso
abríamos la charla con una canción que
se basa en las leyes de la termodinámica
y como las leyes de la termodinámica hay
muchas teorías de tippingpoint la teoría
de bart de que los enunciados son
cadenas que se transmiten de generación
en generación la teoría de los grafos la
neurociencia el block change el adn
steve jobs dijo en una célebre charla
que los puntos se conectan hacia atrás
la teoría de los seis grados de
separación y seguro a todos madres
padres abuelos nos han dicho alguna vez
lo importante son los contactos todas
esas teorías que enumeren están
concentradas en las teorías de las redes
pero la verdad es que las teorías no nos
modifican no son bandera uno no se hace
carne solo de teorías al menos que
logren transformar transformarnos la
vida y yo traigo modestamente acá la
teoría de las redes y como logro al
menos modificar un poco mi vida como
escuchaban soy empujado un pequeño
pueblo del sur santafesino y estamos en
una época de feria de ciencias en la
secundaria y empezamos a investigar
sobre el lenguaje del chat y escribimos
un trabajo de feria de ciencia una
docente escribe una nota y esa nota la
ve un productor muy conocido y
terminamos en una entrevista con lalo
mir y este vídeo llega a parís a una
exposición de docentes y un teórico muy
reconocido un teórico que nosotros
habíamos estudiado parece proyecto de
feria de ciencia escribe sobre nuestro
proyecto mi 'vieja' googleando vaya a
saber que encuentra esa nota me avisa y
automáticamente me pongo en contacto con
ese referente
y en muy poco tiempo estaba trabajando
no sólo con él sino para multinacionales
de tecnología microsoft fundación
telefónica hablando de los nativos
digitales hablando de las redes
y ahí hay un clic como siempre un
pequeño clic y entiendo que en realidad
si la tecnología había logrado eso en
tan poco tiempo tenía que ser sí o sí un
instrumento de transformación y armó mi
primer proyecto de alfabetización
digital en situación de vulnerabilidad
que se llamó huellas digitales este
proyecto tuvo todo una lógica de redes
que es la que les quiero contar este
proyecto no solo lo asocie la ciudad de
buenos aires al cmd a la fundación ruta
40 a mercado de libre a la fundación
moir y alsea a la universidad nacional
de rosario a una sucesión de actores que
fueron transitando y fueron dándole vida
a esa idea incipiente a esa idea de que
la tecnología hace una interfaz de que
la tecnología ayude a conectar mundos
que están desconectados
este proyecto evoluciona evoluciona y se
convierte en la primera empresa de
impacto zinc de latinoamérica era una
empresa que brindaba servicios de
tecnología siempre entrenando a
comunidades en situación de
vulnerabilidad porque la lógica era la
lógica de generar inclusión a personas
que tengan altas barreras de ingreso en
el mundo laboral
pero en realidad estamos hablando de
redes y a veces no todas las redes
generan el mismo impacto no todas las
redes tienen un desenlace feliz y me
tengo que ir tengo que abandonar esa
empresa que fue el amor de mi vida
laboral por una mala red de socios
a veces las ideas no cuentan si
claramente el equipo si el equipo no es
consistente no es sólido y no está
alineado de los valores pero hace muy
poquito en este año el amigo de un amigo
me obligó a rearmar la idea y hoy sigue
en funcionamiento incluyendo a
comunidades trans la tecnología
nuevamente como interfaz y la red
otra vez ayudando sanando tendiendo
espacios
qué es lo más importante o al menos lo
que lo que evoluciona o lo que logra
transformar las redes siempre nos sirven
para articular para sostener proyectos
nos sirven para entramar eso es lo más
valioso cuando me voy a la empresa no
solo esa lógica de utilizar las redes
como base para el diseño de proyectos
sociales sustento es el laboratorio
original sino todos los emergentes que
después surgieron armamos el ministerio
de educación hace muy poquito del plan
volvió a estudiar virtual estuve aquí en
esta comunidad coordinando el área de
educación para ternium municipalidad de
san nicolás y un montón de emergentes
incluso la propia fundación que hoy
coordino de la bolsa de comercio tiene
solamente esa lógica de base no podemos
pensar los proyectos sociales sin entra
amarnos sin aterrizar en el territorio
sin la lógica de tender redes
es que al fin y al cabo las redes pueden
transformar la vida de las personas un
contacto con otro realmente pueden
cambiar la lógica de circulación y de
funcionamiento de los proyectos en este
caso por supuesto es el son los
proyectos sociales son los proyectos que
están atravesados al menos en mi caso
por una vocación profunda de comunidad
las redes tienen un potencial de
transformación y si no por ejemplo
fíjense en los países que tienen mayor
índice de suicidio los países que tienen
mayores indicadores incluso en la
población adolescente son aquellos en
los que falla la cohesión social en los
que fallan las redes en los que uno se
queda sin poder preguntar o asistir a
otros en los que uno se queda claramente
sin otro lituania letonia son los países
que tienen mayor indicador de suicidio
en el mundo y ese sistema de cohesión es
el sistema de saber que puedo contar
con la espalda de otro es lo que genera
mayor suicidio pero eso en términos
negativos por supuesto en términos
positivos hay nombres y apellidos hay
nombres y apellidos a los que la lógica
del contacto les cambia la historia y si
no puedo enumerar el caso del león yo sé
que a león su vida se le transformó
después de un taller en el barrio en la
república de lasexta donde nosotros
estábamos los primeros talleres se que
aflora haberse contactado con francos la
ayuda del esfuerzo a su primer proyecto
estoy muy segura de que juan logró una
escalabilidad que nunca se hubiese
imaginado a raíz de ingresar al contacto
con sandra de formalizar sus proyectos
de darle escalabilidad incluso siempre
lo cuento de alguna manera graciosa pero
sí que claro está muy contenta después
de que yo le haya presentado a su actual
novio aunque haya sido un ex las redes
generan siempre una dimensión que no
podemos dejar de pensar en esa
articulación y como los folletos de
galliano
no todas las redes son iguales no todas
las redes generan la misma fluidez el
mismo dinamismo hay redes que claramente
son más propensas a la expansión y la
riqueza de una red está justamente en
cuando no podemos dimensionar a dónde
llegó si yo pierdo la noción si yo no
puedo dimensionar el impacto directo o
indirecto que genera la red el contacto
que yo artículo es cuando esa red tiene
aún más potencia
qué pasaría si nosotros si todos los que
estamos acá dispusiéramos de nuestras
redes para ayudar a resolver problemas
emergentes cotidianos para resolver la
vida de alguien que está cerca si
nosotros tuviésemos la generosidad de
disponer de esas redes para transformar
mínimamente la cotidianeidad
el perder dimensión del impacto el
entender que nunca podemos controlar qué
tan exponencial puede ser el vínculo que
generemos es lo que le da mayor riqueza
a las redes
es a su vez cada una de las redes que
nosotros entrábamos un gesto de
confianza son como los protocolos de
redes de gentes jake es dar la mano a
las redes son un circulante de energía
son un circulante de gestos de confianza
por eso hay que cuidarlas por eso como
la economía circular solamente existe si
está en movimiento no hay red sin nodo y
todos todos somos nodos hay nodos como
les decía que son mas intempestivos hay
nodos que naturalmente concentran una
alta circulación y hay nuevos que
también destruyen sin lugar a dudas
en mi caso y porque tengo la posibilidad
y agradezco el espacio
el tener redes no sólo es una forma de
ser y hacer es una forma un poco crónica
de vincularme con los otros es también
una cosmovisión una forma de ver el
mundo como dice del ies la cosmogonía es
el espacio donde se desarrolla el
ingenio de uno es en algún punto un
paradigma un sistema no puedo operar sin
red no funciona de otra forma y aunque
muchas veces uno quisiera correrse de su
naturaleza correrse de esa forma y de
esa disposición
somos como dijo una amiga no se trata no
se trata de lo que hago se trata de lo
que soy y en algún punto de redes de
redes somos
a su vez
la pregunta es por qué tendremos redes
para que articulamos con qué sentido en
un mundo que cada vez más tiende a la
independencia necesitamos la
articulación necesitamos la espalda de
otro necesitamos seguir tendiendo redes
quizás la respuesta está en la propia
etimología o al menos es un buen
ejercicio volver a la raíz y la
etimología de la palabra redes viene del
latín red que tiene que ver con la maya
para pescar y es la misma es la misma
raíz que retina redes y retina comparten
lingüísticamente el origen entonces en
esta búsqueda de entender por qué por
qué bueno hace redes porque uno deja
redes
quiero compartir con ustedes
un cuentito y antes
una idea en realidad en las propias
palabras en general están encerradas
todas las comisiones
en el cuento que tengo para compartir
con ustedes
tiene que ver con la lógica de la mirada
tiene que ver con la lógica del mar
tiene que ver con la lógica de la red
y no solo me define y aprovechó el
espacio para compartirlo sino que
responde a esa pregunta
el cuento se llama la función del arte y
es también de eduardo galeano
diego
no conocía la mar su padre santiago
kovadloff lo llevó a descubrirla
ella la mar estaba más allá de los
saltos médanos esperando
después de mucho caminar
con mucho cansancio cuando por fin
alcanzaron esas cumbres arenosas
la mar estalló ante sus ojos
y fue tanto el fulgor fue tanta la
inmensidad de la mar
que el niño quedó mudo de hermosura
y cuando por fin logró hablar
tartamudeando
temblando
le pidió
a su padre
ayúdame a mirar
y ese ayúdame a mirar para ese ayúdame a
mirar para eso
tendremos redes para que en este mundo
que está desarticulado que muchas veces
está agrietado que muchas veces está
descendido atravesado por numerosas
brechas para que en ese mundo es sin
nido entre todos nosotros nos ayudemos a
mirar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]